dessins collages découpages en famille
pendant les vacances scolaires le centre
social albert-schweitzer de magny les
hameaux a organisé la semaine de la
parentalité sur les deux semaines des
vacances scolaires ont organisé semaine
d'animations on propose des ateliers des
conférences pour les parents et leurs
enfants
l'objectif de ces ateliers si lutter
contre l'isolément des parents créer un
moment convivial en dehors des
contraintes de la vie quotidienne malgré
de nombreux ateliers annulés par les
prestataires l'atelier la kawa des
familles a été maintenue par la rade
lundi mardi et jeudi de 15 heures à 16
heures 30
l'imoca oies en arabe ça veut dire à la
paroisse excellent café etc a fait
souvent ses déliés d'échangé de partage
où les gens y viennent pour on a lutté
contre l isolement et discuté il ya les
skis réflexion parce qu'ils et on a
proposé trois questions aux parents et
donc ils ont choisi avec leurs enfants
une question aux sur quoi il va les
changer
le voyage de tai réf le métier de tes
rêves que sais-tu bien faire les
familles ont eu le choix entre trois
questions pour s'évader en
confectionnant leur propre nuage
décoratifs j'ai fait un nuage ou jamais
des questions de meetic que je
or plus d'un j'ai trouvé
voir et vous tourner et ma mère pour
faire un nuage pourrait on dire qu'est
ce que je sais bien faire
moi je me suis dit que j'aimerais bien
aller en australie
des courroies mountain je me suis dit
que c'était kestrel des moments de
convivialité partagé en famille avant
leur confinement et leur rentrée
scolaire